ربما تكون القوات الروسية التي احتلت محطة
للطاقة النووية في تشيرنوبيل قد
تعرضت لجرعات كبيرة من
الإشعاع ، وفقًا
لشركة الطاقة الحكومية
الأوكرانية والوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية
قالت الليلة أنه عندما
احتلت القوات الروسية الموقع لأول مرة ، أطلقت الحركة على
الأرض إشعاعات.  الآن
يمكن أن يتسبب التعرض للإشعاع بجرعات عالية في
أضرار مروعة للأعضاء الداخلية
ونخاع العظام وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض في
مايو كلينك ،
فقد يكون الأمر مروعًا للغاية
من حيث الموت ديفيد ماكنزي في المقدمة و
ديفيد ما الذي نعرفه أيضًا عن هذا
جيدا إيرين نحن  إعادة تجميع الأجزاء
معًا في القصة ، وقد يكون الأمر
مزعجًا للغاية أن تتذكر تلك
الصور المزعجة للدبابات وهي تتجه إلى
تشيرنوبيل في بداية هذا
الصراع ، وكان لديك الروس يستولون
على تشيرنوبيل بشكل فعال ويجعلون هؤلاء
العمال رهائن الآن المزيد من التفاصيل
قادمة  في ما يبدو وفقًا لتلك
الوكالة التي تصفها ،
تم حفر هؤلاء الجنود الروس  وضع
التحصينات
والخنادق في ما
يعرف بالغابة الحمراء الآن هذا داخل
منطقة الحظر تلك المنطقة حول
تشيرنوبيل بعد أسوأ
حادث نووي من نوعه في التاريخ
والذي شهد بعضًا من أسوأ التداعيات من
تلك
المفاعلات وإذا كانت كذلك  يعتقد الخبراء في تلك المنطقة
وحفر الخنادق
أنهم قد تعرضوا بالفعل
لمستويات عالية من الإشعاع
التي قالت الوكالة أن الساعات الأربع والعشرين الماضية أو
حتى أن الجنود الروس أصيبوا بالذعر
لأنهم غادروا خلال الـ 24
ساعة الماضية وهذه المنطقة الآن تحت
السيطرة الأوكرانية  نحن نعتقد ولكن غير واضح إلى
أي مدى إذا كان هؤلاء الجنود
هم هؤلاء الجنود الصغار ، تذكر
أيضًا
أن الروس قد تعرضوا لانتقادات كبيرة
بشأن الإجراءات حول
المفاعلات النووية التي تستخدم المدفعية الثقيلة حول
zaparuja ،
فهم لا يزالون يسيطرون على ذلك
الموقع النووي.
تخبر وكالة الطاقة الذرية اليوم CNN
أنه ربما كان هناك بعض الارتفاع في
مستويات الإشعاع بسبب هو  أفي
درع
في تلك المنطقة من تشيرنوبيل ، يقول إنه
ربما يكون قد سقط ، وهم
يبحثون بشكل عاجل عن إجابات من
الروس حول ما إذا كان هناك أي نوع من
المرض
من هؤلاء الجنود في
أعقاب مغادرة
تشيرنوبيل ، كما يقول إنه يتطلع إلى
التوجه إلى  تلك المنطقة في أقرب وقت ممكن
للتحقيق في إيرين